hello everyone my name is Matt you're
watching code tech tutorials and I hope
you're all doing as well as can be
during these times I think it's time we
continue the FPS tutorial then I started
on unreal and I just wanted to show you
guys a few more things that I'm gonna
show in my notes here now I hope this is
readable but I'll read it just in case
so the first thing I'm gonna show is how
to get the UI and you're in an HP bar or
meters in general kind of going on your
screen and I also want to talk a little
bit about HP region handling different
HP levels and of course my favorite
thing sound of Excel of sound effects I
really think they bring games to to life
in horror sound effects I'm gonna show
you very quickly how to just well you
can use any sound effect of course but
if you don't want to ever run into any
copyright stuff I'm going to show you
how to make your own super easily super
quickly and that's just using audacity
you might already know how to do this
but I'm gonna show you a few tricks to
make it a little bit faster and easier
so stick around for that
I just fell audacity like that I think
that's right so that's basically what
we're gonna go over today now I've
considered that since this is an FPS
tutorial maybe I should do all the
shooting stuff first but I think getting
kind of some meters going and the HP
handling and sound effects ready first
it's sorta more important because like
what's the point of hitting things with
things and if you can't actually do of
any HP changing and it has no effect on
the world you know that's it's not very
fun so if we get it so that actually
things can be affected first then it's
gonna have more meaning later so that's
why I'm kind of not going to that yet so
without further ado let's get right in
I'm going to show you the UI first and
then we'll do some stuff with HP and
then some and some clever little sound
effects at the end okay so where we left
off from last tutorial and if you
haven't seen it maybe you should watch
it but basically I'll go over super
super quick basically all we did was we
got this mouse movement going on a
first-person guy and we got the walking
around with WASD and we got a jump going
and we have a boost with shift so if you
hold shift you
faster so that's what we set up in the
first tutorial and I can just double
click on our FPS guy here I'm going to
drag this window so it locks up at the
top and there are the nodes all that we
did from the first tutorial I'll glaze
over them just as a previously on FPS
game tutorials or whatever you know that
way you can pause and duplicate or
whatever you want to do take note of the
is there any variables no I don't really
have any variables okay so we're gonna
introduce some variables and in this new
set up okay so first thing we want to do
is we want to get a I now we need it to
design the UI and then we can construct
it on our characters begin place so
let's go design it first so we went back
to our default screen and I'm just gonna
right click in our content area and do a
blue print class I think that's what we
want no no okay
yeah this is kind of a little different
you got to go down a user interface so
right click and go to user interface and
then look for widget blueprint that's
what we're gonna be using here so you
click that you give it a name I don't
know I'm just call VP UI you want to
call it something a little different
that's fine and then I just opened it up
there and this is the default area it
takes you to now I'm gonna talk a little
bit about this UI because it confused me
some at first but it seems the main
things you need to know is well there's
tabs up here you can be in designer mode
or you can be in graph mode there were
times when I was like our trying to file
will follow this tutorial but my screen
is completely different and like 90% of
the time it was I didn't notice this up
here so you have two different modes
here when you're designing a blueprint I
think this is for pretty much all some
blueprints so some of them have this
some of them don't I'm still a little
new to unreal so I don't fully yeah I
haven't experienced everything in here
yet okay so we're in the designer right
now and we're just going to drop in on
HP bar because that's really the only
thing we want right now but as you can
see from this palette
over here there's a lot of different
stuff there's common stuff and there's
some more advanced stuff and there's all
sorts of things you can do with these if
you've ever done some sort of UI design
before this is probably all pretty
familiar to you but if it's all new play
around some see what things are for now
we're just going to use a progress bar
and this is going to represent our HP
bar so we're gonna drag it in here and
then it automatically selects it and we
get some details
it gives it a name it's progress bar 400
that's not the best name in the world so
we're gonna change this to HP I don't
like the progress bar but so I'm just
gonna put bar but sometimes I personally
like to leave the type in in there like
sometimes I like to say HP or progress
bar HP or something like that
so whatever your project standard is
stick with that the best you can of
course but I don't like to tell people
what to name things you can name on what
you want it often doesn't matter X Y Z W
it'll still do the same thing it's all
about organization when it comes to
naming things alright so you'll see that
is a variable was checked here this is
actually rather important because if
this is not checked you won't be able to
edit this bar not easily anyway I don't
think you'll be able to do it from other
blueprints but if you do have it as a
variable it's easier to edit and more
widely through your project from what I
understand ok so let's go ahead and get
this HP bar designed up a little better
it's gonna by default its from left to
right as the fill you can change the
fill you'll see the appearance here too
so we can change the color even to we're
gonna change it to a green color so all
I did was just click on it and just drag
this to green you see change the
darkness and lightness and there we go
and we can also well let's just go
through these there's an anchor this
we're gonna you know you can do what you
want with anchors I like anchoring it to
the bottom because that way you can kind
of get you can navigate from the bottom
of the screen whatever wherever you want
to navigate from on these positions
is what this changes so if you want it
to always be in the bottom center you
can choose this bottom center anchor and
just change these to zero and it'll
always be there but as you can see
that's not the best um so I'm gonna move
it somewhere else let's just move it top
left that's pretty common and we're
gonna stretch it out a little bit okay
so we're just kind of playing it by ear
we're not doing exact numbers but so you
can move it you know it's a ultimately
it's gonna do the same thing no matter
where you put it but this just gives you
an idea of how to use the designer now I
will say that you do have to kind of
think about different size screens like
some people might be using 1080 some
people might be using 720 so your
experience may vary I don't know how
much this Auto adjusts I think it
thought of just pretty well pretty
reasonably but I haven't really tested
that a whole lot so just FYI okay and we
got a style here let's look at that you
can put a background image you could put
a film in Jamar key image we're not
gonna mess with that today we're gonna
keep it a little more simple but you can
see there's a a progress percent and you
can change this to to be how full it is
now this is our the bread and butter of
this whole thing really is changing this
percent to fill how much of the bar you
want and you can see the fill type here
too so you can go like bottom to top and
make it wide sound like this you know
and it works essentially the same so
that's all in that progress I want to
keep it left to right and I'll basically
back to how I had it I'll just do it up
here okay and so how do you make this
percent represent your health well we're
gonna end up doing that with this bind
button and when I click this and click
create binding it goes to the graph and
it starts a little function that says
okay how do you want to fill this
percent bar so we'll have to fill out
this function which is in blueprint form
Oh
we don't have any variables to work with
yet as far as how much HP the player has
so let's just go ahead and compile and
save here and go back to the character
but also it's not gonna just show the UI
because you build a blueprint it's just
a blueprint that's sitting here and
isn't in the world or in use yet so we
also have to put it in our world and
it's there seems to be a lot of
different ways to do this but since it's
the characters UI I like doing it on the
characters begin play I think that makes
sense so basically we just drag off this
begin play construct object from class
yeah this is it construct object from
class and then you got to change this
class to be P UI so that's a little
weird but that's how it is and this
outer one right here is our self so we
construct it and then we want to add it
to our report so we drag off this one
and add to viewport and of course the
hit the target is this UI
and that's really all we need to do to
just add it to our screen when we start
because as this instantiates it's gonna
construct that VP UI and add it to our
viewport so go ahead NIT play and as we
can see it's up at the top there this
shift plus every one things in the way
but it's it is up at the top there
there's a little bar that's our HP bar
so now if we go back in here to BP UI
and back to the designer we can we can
give it a default percent just to make
sure it actually does that real quick so
let's just do that
it didn't yeah okay so that's not auto
showing the percent that we expect it's
because it's being overridden by this
get HP percent bar thing so if we remove
this binding then it's gonna default
back to just whatever its default value
is so that's why it's because we created
that binding that kept at zero and did
nothing
so later we'll update that binding to
update our little bar there okay very
good so let's go back to our FPS
character and we're just going to add in
some HP so over here and variables we're
gonna have a max HP and we want this to
be a float floats good here and we're
also going to have current HP so max HP
and current HP now once you compile
you're allowed to give these default
values so I hit compile there and I'm
going to click back over to max HP and
let's just do the max HP at 100 we're
not we're not gonna edit that in this
tutorial but of course if you're doing
some kind of game or RPG this is
something that might change over time
and we can talk about that later so our
current HP we're gonna just set it to 25
that should be that should be fine for
starting out so very good now we have
some max HP and some current HP and now
we can use those in a function on this
HP bar so go ahead and go back to this
binding or we'll set it back to the one
we already created but and now to view
it you've got to go back to graph and
you'll find it over here on the side and
there's HP bar so what we're gonna do
here is
it says get HP bar % but we're gonna be
using this as more of an update for so
I'm gonna rename this by pressing f2 and
call this update HP bar so anytime the
HP bar updates this will handle it so
first of all what we want to know is is
what we're interacting with the
character so this is only related to the
character we want to make sure were we
have our character that were working
with when this is updating so the first
thing we're going to do is a cast to be
PE FPS character and then this object
here is gonna be the player character
get player character so this only works
on the that player character class very
specifically if you're in making another
class you'll have to do a different UI
so this UI in that way is kind of tied
into this FPS character so if the cast
is successful then we go to the returned
note but we want to not just go to the
return node this is returning 0 as you
can see there but we want to do some
stuff from this player character mainly
with that current HP and Max HP and if
you want to do a percent of course you
just put the current HP divided by the
max HP so we'll drag off of this as BP
FPS character and say we want to do get
current HP and that's that variable from
our other class and we can get it
because we're casting to that class only
want another one that is so we'll drag
off again in and just look for max HP
and get max HP and then of course we
want a division here so I'm going to
drag off and just hit the slash and look
for the float / float there it is with
the current on top bottom max on the
bottom and the result is going to be
here so as you can see from our starting
out we're going to have 25 current HP
and 100 max HP so
what's gonna happen here is this bar is
gonna be 25% filled if everything was
successful there it is looks about 25%
filled that's perfect okay so we don't
actually have a way to change it yet so
the next step would be okay so what if
the changes with a great thing about
this function to update the HP bar is if
our HP changes on our character this bar
just automatically adapts so that's
super cool and makes it super easy we
are going to add a little bit of HP
regen so over time our character is
going to regenerate this is going to use
a few new concepts mainly with our Delta
time we're gonna actually start using
our delta time to see how long it's been
so we're gonna have a couple variables
for this event tick to see if it's time
to regen a hit point so say we want to
read it regenerate one hit point every
three seconds that's the only condition
we're gonna give now just to default one
hit point every three seconds in a real
game of course is gonna be different
maybe you don't want to regen till
you've been out of combat for a while or
something so you'd have more stuff but
we're going to keep it simple here and
just to have a very base region so we're
gonna add a very some variables to help
handle this condition so we're gonna
have an HP regen or we'll just call it
regen we're just gonna call it regen
tick it's kind of hard to come up with
names that work really well here but
basically this is regen tick is going to
be our constant that is how often we
regenerate coopcent
ticks and we're gonna do three seconds
there so I was able to compile and then
just default it to three optionally you
can default all these by dragging off
this and doing set regen tick and then
set it to three and that also on begin
play so three I think that just kind of
clutters up the area a little more since
you can just put default values right
here but to each his own okay so every
three seconds
and then we need to know how much time
is passed
so we need to kind of accumulate we're
not kind of we do actually need to
accumulate Delta time until we hit three
seconds and then at three seconds we
want to region in it a hit point and
then reset how much time we've
accumulated so that way we can get every
three seconds of Delta time passing so
to do that we'll need an accumulator so
we'll have in a regen tick I'm just
gonna call it a CC so this is of course
going to default to zero and what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna have well
we're gonna have a branch to start and
this branch
I'll explain it's just an F and the
condition is if current HP we wanting to
get current HP if your current HP is
above or equal to your maximum you don't
need to regen any more so that's what
this is a very first check is otherwise
you're gonna regenerate above your
maximum HP and your games gonna be
glitchy and you're gonna get bad reviews
on Steam so we want to take the current
HP we're going to drag off of it see if
it's greater than or equal to another
float and that other float is going to
be our thematics HP so if current HP is
greater than max HP
well I think I'm doing it in Reverse
here we only want to regen if current HP
is less than max HP so I'm doing a
backwards of the check there no worries
as long as it's less than the max HP
then this condition is true so if this
returns true we drag off here and do our
true let's head up so what we're going
to do is we're going to set our region
take accumulator and we're going to
increase it by our delta time so we need
to get the current regen tick whatever
it's currently at and add the delta time
to it so I'm gonna go do this again and
just get the region get regen tick
accumulator and we're just going to do a
plus another float and the other flow is
going to be Delta time which comes off
this tick here and then we just drag the
result into there so that is going to
add the Delta time to the regen take
accumulator very good and the next thing
we want to do is we want to see if this
accumulated time is above our region
tick is above 3 if it's above 3 we need
to do our next part so here we're gonna
have yet another if statement so we're
just gonna doing if there and this time
you can probably imagine we're going to
see if read region tick accumulation
we're going to see if it's greater than
the region tick so this is greater I
could probably do greater equal because
I want it to it's going to be a very
rare case that they're equal but might
as well because if it's exactly 3
seconds that fits it - I think we should
regen there we go I'm just moving it
over so if the region take accumulation
is greater than our region tick that we
said go ahead and say true here so if
this is true we're going to set our
current HP and what we're going to set
it to
well whatever our current HP is already
so we get whatever it already was and
we're going to add some number to it so
we're gonna do another plus here and for
now we're just gonna add two whole
region to hitpoints every three seconds
or maybe we can do three hit points
every three seconds so let's do that
that makes a little easier to read
actually sorry change mind again I'm
just gonna stick with one no no no no I
have an idea here I'm gonna do something
a little different than I actually
planned
let's do three let's say you region
three hit points every tick and what
this introduces is the possibility that
your current goes over your max because
what if you're at ninety nine so you're
less than max but then you regen to 103
but you're only allowed 100 you knows
your max is hundred so you have to have
a condition for that is what it comes
down to so we're going to drag this over
a little further because there's going
to be a little more logic here so
current HP we're gonna add 3 to it and
then we're gonna drag out of this and
get the result and if the result is
greater than or yeah we'll say greater
than max HP well I'm sorry I just need a
greater here first and then we'll just
get max HP so if this result is greater
than the max HP and this is gonna be
true otherwise it's going to be false
and we just set all right so let's add a
few different conditions here we need
another yet another gift statement so
right click type an if and this branch
is gonna have to go through here too so
basically if it's time to regen we go
ahead and do the regen and if it's
greater than the max HP then we're gonna
set our HP to max HP because we don't
want to go over we would rather just set
it to max so that way we don't
regenerate to 102 and break our game get
batteries on Steam instead we just
regenerate to 100 all right and if it's
false
what we want to do here is we want to
take this result we want to do a set
current HP but now it's just the the
result that we got from here
because we know we're not going over we
already did that check here and the
answer was false and it looks like we're
done but there's one actually really
important thing or we will still get a
bad review on Steam and that's we have
to reset this region tick accumulation
so if you did end up regenerating you
need to not regenerate again for three
seconds so the only thing we need to do
here is on either of these cases is just
set region tick accumulation back to
zero as it starts over and I'm just
going to copy it paste it and do the
same thing here either case we said can
we change it back to zero okay and we
are looking pretty good here
now I will say I'm just joking about
this bad review on steam thing but it is
what enrages people when bugs are in
your game and it's totally possible that
I'm doing this in a buggy way because
I'm kind of new to unreal but I'm just
trying to be funny trying to make this
humorous a little more enjoyable alright
so there's just playing around here I
got this all selected box select and now
I'm just going to right click and create
a comment and I'm just gonna call this
HP region so that way when we go back in
here later we can just take a peek of
this box but like okay this is where all
our region happens so in case there's a
bug it's very easy to find and now all
we want to do is basically just hit play
on our game and confirm that we
regenerate some hit points and we should
see this bar move every three seconds
there goes there goes there goes and
yeah it looks like this is working very
well
we're regenerating some hit points and
now this auto scales so if you're max HP
is much higher this three will look a
lot tinier so these this progress bar
handles all of that okay so now we got
an HP bar we got some passive
regeneration the next thing we need is a
way to take damage and some stuff to
happen now I said I would do it in this
episode I think I got the HP regen and a
little bit of HP handling I'm sort of
running out of time
so I'm not gonna go to any further into
handling right now I'm just gonna do
some really quick last-minute sound
effect things to make it sound cooler so
what if when you reach in a point some
you get some sound because that's really
the only thing we do know I guess we
could do it on jump we could make a jump
sound but you can in theory drag off of
all any of these and just do play sound
at location and you can make your
character make whatever sound you want
and what you do here is you just go into
this and look for select a set and I
have some default ones already but I
said I would teach you how to make your
own so I'm gonna do that and I'm not
gonna use any of these default ones but
just to show you that works I'm gonna
click one of these I don't know what
this is collapsed to so when we jump
we'll get it collapsed to sound and if
you want to make your own let me just
launch audacity here okay I'm gonna
bring audacity over you can just launch
audacity and through your microphone
like this one I'm talking in right now
the better your microphone the better
you can hit record and then make your
jump sound huh and then stop and you can
see right here where I made the little
hook I can highlight it and then just
say play and get a little huh sound so
what you can do here now that you have
it selected as you go to file export
export selected audio and give it a name
and let's see I'm I want to put this in
the library of this project I'm doing so
give me a second
no projects this one was called fps demo
content and I have stuff there so I'm
just gonna make a new folder called
audio and go into it and we'll just call
this huh however you say that hu
audacity a lot allows you to put meta
tags in not really caring about that for
a little huh sound there we go it is now
exported and move this all the way now a
cool thing about unreal is its ease
that a new ass or asset has come into
your folders for this project and asked
you if you want to import it and you
just click import and it'll do the thing
now
also maybe you saw it but I did import
our export as a dot wave 16-bit dot wave
there's a lot of different file types
I'm not an expert on all these file
types I just tend to use 16-bit waves
because it's simple easy and they're
relatively small and by about everything
supports it ok so now that we imported
it it should now show up in our assets
so I mean just type the name of that huu
and now when we jump we should get this
hearse out it's kind of quiet there but
you can hear it
oh my you can't hear the sound at all
hold on sorry guys I just have to change
it on my recording device to actually
pick up the speakers okay okay sure
sorry about that
and yeah so now we got we got that we
got the regen when we got you know some
more elements and maybe you can get a
lot of ideas just from there about what
to do next and some more ideas but we'll
cover that in the next episode this
one's getting a bit long and I want to I
think in the next episode I'll get a
little more into building some elements
of the of the game and getting some
interactions and some maybe some start
and end cases that you can potentially
add thank you so much for watching keep
clear guys keep code and keep working
away take care of yourselves I
appreciate all of you very much thank
you all very much for the support it
still blows me away to this day to know
that you know I just started this
channel somewhat goofing thinking I'm
just gonna do some sarcastic coding
tutorials in that now I have over 500
people on here because I don't know it
just blows me away that communities can
come together like this it's very cool
and I want you to know that I appreciate
it and I take it seriously and take care
of yourselves out there guys
peace out
you